cet après midi 22 pour les maximales
elles lundi politique
gaël le dantec lundi politique avec jean
paul virapoullé votre invité égaler le
dantec
bonjour bonjour j'ai six mois tous on a
parfois avancer la femme sa carrière
politique lui même une époque avait dit
vouloir se consacrer à son rôle de
grand-père
certains dans son camp ont traité de
dinosaures voire même de traître mais il
en faut décidément plus pour lui faire
prendre une vraie retraite
malgré tout ils amorcent un retrait en
annonçant qu'il ne se représentera pas
la mairie de saint-andré en mars
prochain son nom au pourtant devrait
l'être être bien présent puisque son
fils jean marie sera lui candidat pour
lui succéder mais peut-on transmettre
une mairie en héritage qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
le poids de notre invité dans le jeu
politique réunionnais quel regard
porte-t-il sur la droite réunionnaise
sur l'action du gouvernement sur le vote
nationaliste à la réunion jean paul
virapoullé maire de saint-andré pression
de la cirest conseil régional est avec
nous sur la première jusqu'à 13h vos
questions au 02 62 99 demi à partir de
12h45
bonjour je préfère plus bonjour des le
dantec savoir accepté notre invitation
dans l'actualité aujourd'hui à la
commission départementale de la nature
des paysages et des sites qui doit
donner son avis sur une mise à jour du
schéma des carrières de 2010 une mise à
jour qui propose d'ajouter aussi deux
gros blanc vous allez participer vous en
tant qu' en tant qu'élu à 7 à cette
réunion non je ne fais pas partie de
cette commission qui est souveraine qui
doit fournir un travail très important
puisque il vivra de la continuité la
route du littoral
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que à la
réunion on les dossiers ne sont pas
traitée avec la transparence qui font
bien c'est à dire je veux dire par là
que lorsqu'on a démarré le projet de la
route du littoral une partie était en
viaduc et une partie en digue l apathie
on dit le groupement qui a soumissionné
ac s'est quand même engagé auprès du
président de région pour une quantité de
galets pour une qualité de galles
et pour un prix galles et à fournir d'un
temps donné ça ce sont les clauses du
marché public à sensibilité pour vous ce
sont les entreprises qui ont pré marché
google talk
je suis boulanger jeu marc boulanger
vends ma pote et quand vous venez
chercher le pain vous voyez que je n'ai
pas de farine et je vous dis je peux par
m'approvisionner j'ai donc menti à mes
clients comme le bouquet invite à manger
car les riches en gaz
et quand arrivera la traque aux débris
la poule et leila marché dupe et quand
c'est pas trois ans et là il n'y a pas
de pause un prochain sega les parce que
le marché des bases et se garer malgache
il ça revient plus cher et du coup
maintenant trop trop sûr j'allais dire
presque une voie sans issue mais ce que
je ne comprends pas cb que j'ai été élu
maire
mon prédécesseur monsieur fruteau à la
demande du préfet et j'ai continué le
dossier qu'il avait ouverte avait dit
préfet ou big et le dur est passé des
années à durer en bon maire j'ai exécuté
lors du préfet maintenant on me dit non
il n'ya plus guère à nous régaler marche
pas il ya un problème
moi je pense que sur l affaire qu'est ce
que vous savez sur ce retour et c'est
parce que le préfet
je prends ministre hâtif jeu doit
exécuter les ordres du préfet piguet le
terrain puis se fait un programme
d'intérêt général
parce qu'il ya des galets pour ferrari
depuis trois ans a besoin sous les feux
des critiques j'ai fait le terrain est
épique et maintenant le puig est retombé
mais personne après les galets on dit
qu'il ya des galets dans les eaux de
saint-andré aussi à l'ermitage on dit
qu'il ya des galets à saint paul ont dit
qu'is que les galets ont dit que les
galets je prends mes responsabilités de
la ravine du trou ne sont pas ceux dont
on aura besoin pour la rhune vite oral
entre 500 kg et 7 tonnes et on entend
dire que même la crise les cadres de
bois blond ça c'est faux je suis en
train de vous dire en bon créole et en
bon français et je prends rendez vous
chez vos antennes que lorsqu on ouvrira
la carrière de la ravine du trou
si on peut l'ouvrir on pourra pas
nourrir en entier parce qu'il y a des
terrains agricoles situées en seule
antenne 4 qui était subventionné à
l'époque par mes soins via le roi pour
faire l'irrigation
ce sont des terrains d'école qu'on ne
peut pas extraire du périmètre du col
mais que la pratique que l'on prend en
carrière d'après les sondages ont fait
quatre sondages
les quatre sondages révèlent que ces
terrains ne contiennent pas les roches
massives en quantité nécessaire via la
route du littoral et en qualité aussi
donc moi je dis j'appelle à une
transparence sur le dossier et nous nous
refait qui vient d'arriver jusqu'à ta
pour la bienvenue sur vos temples et à
liège 1 et bon courage
boncourt année le courage ou à la limite
même pas il va tout mettre sur la table
et 10 rebonds veillaient dégâts les lie
des galets y en a pas si anna paquin
solution trouve on pourra pas faire une
deux tiers de route et déboucher sur une
voie sans issue
il ya quand même la vie économique
qui est en jeu je pense que les
entreprises du groupe ont une dette
vis-à-vis de la région ses conseillères
régionales jeudi vous avez une dette
vis-à-vis de moi vous avez promis de
faire la route avec des deux fourni
régalez vous devez le faire
les gens préfèrent appeler dans
l'actualité également il y avait cette
annonce qu'on a reçu ce matin par mail
dino veste qui recrutent 35 personnes je
crois une loi c'est la filiale de
filiale de suez qui porte le projet de
gestion des déchets pour signer le
syndicat intercommunal du nord et de
l'est pour donc avec ce projet on le
sait que certains ont qualifié
d'incinérateur alors de gestion multi
filières suivantes comment est-ce que
quoi ce qu'on appelle un projet contre
lequel vous vous êtes positionnés montre
président de la cirest entre maire de
saint-andré vous voyez pas six concerts
que c'est à dire que c'est sur les races
et non c'est petit c'est du chantage
tout ça je veux dire aux réunionnaises
rennais attention la france est passée
sur les pays qui sont considérés comme
les pays corrompus
cette grande démocratie celle de
voltaire nous rouchaud wikio et 31
aujourd'hui chambrer dans la corruption
hopper nationale et ceux de cidre est en
et non par exemple la coach en est
l'exemple du mauvais respect de la loi
du général maillot en tant président de
ciné je suis mangue le signer a signé un
marché de 253 millions d'euros pas
groupies sans publicité et en missouk et
ça c'est toujours la justice alors
bougez pas je suis allé aux côtés à pour
demander à supporter la destra cif la
suspension le terrain dit non je suis
allé devant la plus haute juridiction
administrative française en tant que
président de la cirest et
vice-présidente ine le conseil d'état
digne celle d'en tester la phrase je
demande au conseil d'état qui pas la
suspension du marché qu'ils méritent
annulation bat gc si le t1
depuis le mois d'octobre de l'année
dernière et j'ai dû ôter à annuler le
théâtre n'a toujours pas annulée on
mais devant le fait accompli on ne met
pas virapoullé devant le fait accompli
aujourd'hui un marché qui est suspendu
j'irai jusqu'au bout pour qu'il soit
annulé
je veux et je sais je sais par contre
compte le procès ce que je suis c'est
pas contre le fait qu'on traite les
ordures au contraire mais les ordures
c'est une mine d'or
et jeudi il est temps d'arrêter de
confier cette mine d'or d'entreprises
privées je veux une société d'économie
mixte entre nous et lui cirais cinor
karl zéro sans cesse croissant pour le
privé jeu contre l'entré jeu contre la
valorisation je comprends les recettes
et les dépenses et le bénéfice 45% je
remets dans la caisse et avec le
président n'a sinon on baisse les
ordures ménagères le fils de la
collection homme d'affaires pour les
gens qui ne peuvent plus payer taxes
si on veut me faire avaler que je serai
ce qui est une multinationale et je n'ai
rien contre suez
moi je suis là pour faire respecter le
code des marchés publics va me poser ce
procès ça on perd son temps on ira
jusqu'au bout et jacques assumera ses
responsabilités
vous vous dites vous ferez d'état
corrompus parler de l'état français que
l'état français corrompus ou mais en
combien de ceux de ce2 ce dossier là
quand même
il ya de la corruption d'un temps il ya
des enjeux financiers pour qui la
corruption quand je demande et c'est
bien ce que je vous dis ce que je vous
dis je suis prêt à le deviendront
j'ai demandé à lire le marché public je
suis en a remis son appel la femme
considère quand même illettrés ou est
taré mais ils n'ont pas de l'énergie
toujours pas le marché qui a été signé
alors c'est pas la corruption
en tout cas c'est la discimination je
vous donne un exemple plus scandaleux
qui me fait mal en tant que patriote
c'est que le général de gaulle a créé la
l'énergie nucléaire par fusion et qui a
dominé le monde
aujourd'hui on va passer à l'énergie
nucléaire
les ventilateurs qui traîne la mer tout
ce qu'on appelle les joliens de panosol
ainsi qu'aux n'y passera plus de
panneaux solaires plus de courant havre
énergie d'asnières c'est là la fission
nucléaire
monsieur le dantec vous êtes contre lui
avait coûté bien ce jeu vous dire on a
on a programmé le pea de flamanville 5
milliards corruption pourriture
il est à 10 milliards et le pm s'ouvrira
pas maintenant parme 2025
edf s'associe aux chinois en chine
ils ont déjà ouvert le pm chinois avec
le brevet français et ça ne plaît à qui
peut alimenter une ville comme paris
hoyé par la france est malade voyez pas
qu'on est en train d'évoluer sur de
mauvais rails
vous voyez pas que on n'est pas
suffisamment sévères et respectueux des
lois votées par le parlement il ya un
problème de fond qui se posent pourquoi
flamanville nous a fait perdre le
leadership sur le nucléaire
excuse moi je préfère vous ramener à la
réunion mais on va continuer à parler de
projets industriels qui quittera plus
plus proche on vous a souvent entendu
parler de ce grand projet pour votre
commune et pour l'est avec avec un port
avec
le développement technologique du
commerce d'eau potable avec un certain
nombre de grands projets comme ça
souvent quand vous êtes venu notre
avance micro vous nous aviez lancé la
révolution et de mettre centre andré sur
la carte du monde ou est ce qu'on en ait
des projets en cours voilà on a franchi
une étape mais s'ils me posent la
question
nous avons soumis notre projet d'éco
technoport bois rouge au gouvernement
qui est souverain et nous avons appris
du premier ministre que nous faisons
partie des 145 à 145 territoire
d'industrie sur lesquels monsieur le
ministre et tous les membres du
gouvernement vont focaliser l'effort de
l'état pour redonner de la substance au
développement industriel français qu'on
fasse on est bien concrètement le de
chez bras rouge été retenu comme projet
comme territoire d'industrie ce
deuxièmement ça nous donne pas encore
qu'un tri car si si si il ya une partie
terrestre et une partie maritime sur la
partie terrestre
nous participons à l'appel à projets de
l'état pour faire la première usine
d'énergie thermique des mers du monde
à saint-andré pour nom un tueur dans la
mer et nous la menons et nous faisons au
sol de l'énergie par différence de
température entre l'eau à 1000 mètres et
l'os hôte surface mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que cherche projets
terrestres
trente cinq grosses entreprises ont déjà
signé leur participation cosmetic valley
edf energy navale al burma et demain
matin nous avons une réunion à
calendrier ou les calendriers appel à
projets 2018 et une 2019 démarrage des
travaux 2020 2021 pour la partie au sol
et pour la partie offshore en mer
cette vidéo vous montre est allé là
voilà en vidéo sont rarissimes
alors vous avez banon l'asie si vous
avez l'afrique ici et nous on est dans
les petits points ça ce trafic maritime
de l'est vers l'ouest aux auditeurs on
est petit on voit trafic évidemment très
important face à frontignan et sur
l'autoroute maritime du monde
l'autoroute maritime collection de
trophées ou des stations service oui non
bâti est bien mieux mais des
stations-service ici pour ravitailler
les bateaux qui passent là en gaz
naturel liquifié parce que d'ici les 15
ans qui viennent on sera mort n'est pas
grave ça mais d'ici 15 ans tous les
bateaux fonctionneront gnl 6 nuls ou le
rendez-vous nous les morts alors comment
n'y fait on est en train de travailler
avec total avec emi avec sa pierre mais
tout ça produit il faut mettre une
station-service ici et prom est
insatiable ici si je vous donne les
détails parce que les études sont
presque terminés il avait eu une valise
et vous aimez calendrier va agréer notre
projet pour la fin de l'année
il ya une pratique au sol qui est déjà
agréé et la pratique offshore est à la
fin d'année nous disons que et cindy
fusion avec le gouvernement il faut que
la central fioul du porc passe au gnl il
faut que je voie burma demain matin pour
voir comment on reconvertit ses
centrales en gnl biomasse ou ans ou en
gnl ou en biomasse m'agace c'est à voir
et puis nous voulons également mettre
transports publics et transports palois
ans au gnl aussi c'est moins cher pour
les propriétaires et c'est moins
polluants le gnl dégradent beaucoup
moins d'oxydé de carbone et je trouve
pas de souffle
voilà on vous entend souvent défendre de
grands projets comme ça mais malgré son
récent qu'un qui sort de terre la france
n'est pas la chine
en chine un projet de du matin phrase
fram a pris sort de terre en français
toutes les commissions
il ya toutes les règles et aujourd'hui
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que l'adhésion
des grandes entreprises françaises comme
cosmetic valley ces 16 milliards de
production quand on restera cette eau je
sentais qu on va la mettre en bouteille
pour que les gens fortunés l'achète et
parce qu'ils croient que salim être en
bonne santé pas fortuit gens achètent
quand cosmetic valley va extraire à bois
rouge
les molécules combien dans les
cosmétiques pour que les gens restent
heures avec une peau bien présentable
lorsqu'on lance avec le conseil général
et toutes les autorités sont d'accord
l'a retrouvée à champs progressive des
salles en culture biologique en culture
médicinales et en plantes à parfum on
est là sur un axe révolutionnaire par
rapport à tous et le projet qui à mon
avis pourquoi il faut le port pourquoi
il faut le pas s'attendre à ce qu'en
france
voilà mais vous savez sont des projets
qui prennent du temps
quelle était ma juste propres la culture
des réunionnais sont des projets qui
prennent du temps parce que nos
interlocuteurs ne parle pas en terme de
subventions ils s'en foutent ils parlent
en termes de marché de faisabilité de
rentabilité à long terme et je vous ai
ramené encore une petite 4 de sécurité
les les départs en intervention
cet inventaire les parlementaire qui dit
jeu supprimé un amendement virapoullé ça
ils savent pas lire
soit ils mesurent pas les conséquences
de ce qu'ils lisent jeu dantec ça c'est
une crainte que je vous emmène ce matin
oui j'ai pensé à vos prenons ce week-end
pour préparer des missions
regardez ça c'est la crainte d akkad des
risques c'est bon là problème c'est la
carte des risques mondiaux
si vous avez 10 ou vous a réussi ses
housses en verre mais si vous avez 6
août en noir ou net j'ai pu retrouver
vos sous je confirme et rigoureux les
australiens la paire ou et rouge c'est
pas la peine mais quelle est la couleur
la réunion c'est marqué le petit progrès
ou donnez vous
on espère pour vérifier le petit point
qui concerne la réunion
le petit preneur et nous avons
d'ailleurs je d'urgence ou aller je suis
qu'on fasse map maps et vous aurez la
coface c'est quoi c'est l'organisme qui
garantit des investissements à
l'étranger et voudrait clar et une autre
en verre nous sommes une terre de
sécurité la seule dans la zone c'est ça
qui va faire j'ai le projet de bras
rouge va réussir à parler de la banque
et qui porte votre nom qui qui détermine
la la possibilité pour d'expérimenter de
t'adapter l'ailé droit national on va
refaire le débat ici sur ce sur sept et
soins mais par rapport à la politique
industrielle mais parfois aussi à
l'aménagement du territoire qui qui qui
vous sont chères en ascension quand même
que qui manque une vision globale de la
réunion on a des intercommunalités des
mairies des des collectivités qui
chacune aura l'impression pour tous
leurs propres projets est ce que est ce
que il faudra malgré tout revoir la
halle des institutions et ce pour avoir
une vision que vous êtes un
professionnel
c'est un problème de l'ambition pour la
réunion d'abord ici on a des élus qui
travaillent contrairement à ce qu'on dit
dans leurs actes communalité dans la
commune travaille il travaille en
fonction de leur carrière ils
travaillent pas en fonction d'une vision
globale gras des affaires la can ça fait
dix ans qu'on dit la can a tremblé rien
que maintenant parce que madame girardin
du mal à défendre des 38 millions
globaux et 28 millions d'euros serait en
feu ben moi je dis aujourd'hui étant
donné qu'on peut planter dab l'étrave du
jour au lendemain en effet la quantité
de sucre que l'on veut la merde à cannes
est compromis il faut qu'on se réunisse
pour dire en place par quoi nous sommes
en train mais il faut qu on se
réunissait ce que je ferai ce que c'est
pas un site us elle manque un problème
devient un problème pour certains sur
nation quand vous voyez une tension
entre le sud et le nord il ya une
tension pour reçu une offre
régionaux comme sud alors vous le dire
vous dire je suis pas non je veux pas
rentrer dans sa en 2010 j'ai mis mon
doigt d'or je me suis brûlé le bras je
les laisse avec leurs problèmes
moi je parle pour l'intérêt général de
la réunion pour l'intérêt général la
réunion quel que soit notre opinion
politique en train de travailler avec
dans la cirest lui rapports sont votés à
plupart du temps à l'unanimité il est
facile sur la sécurité du tunnel de la
réunion sur la position géographique de
la réunion sur la qualité des lois sur
l'importance des crédits européens et
sur le potentiel que représente cette
ils n'ont pas de produire pour à la
réunion ils sont les habitants c'est
trop peu mais de rentrer progressivement
dans la mondialisation et nos projets
avancent puisque epitech est ouvert
l'année prochaine tu es s'est isolé et
nous avons un plier numérique implique
et biotechnologiques un pilier
nanotechnologique un plier énergétique
est un pilier biologique pour toute
l'île alors je vous en fais partie de
ces choses faso à saint-andré dont vous
êtes le maire et pourtant vous ça y est
c'est fini tu voulais plus être le même
sens en moi je vais mourir à saintes en
vrai pour les saint-andré ça c'est sûr
maintenant quel rôle je dois jouer j'ai
plein engagement 2014 alors que j'étais
avec mes petits enfants dans ma piscine
c'est de continuer de rester à la maison
puis j'ai vu c'est pas des liens
d'intérêts communs j'aime les gens déjà
une âme c'est tout après éthique ça se
résume à ça il faut qu'ils l'estiment
fauqué faut qu'ils aient des sentiments
ta population de vaud ils m'ont dit on
revient tonton jédir gros 6 ans à
l'époque l'opposition avait dit non
c'est pas vrai il va faire trois ans va
mettre son fils
c'est pas vrai j'ai tenu les 6 ans est
d'ailleurs jean marie à qui j'ai proposé
un moment donné j'étais fatigué est ce
que tu veux pas prendre ma place il a
dit ceci et je le dis aux réunionnaises
et réunionnais avec raté il m'a dit de
ne pas pas de deux choses l'une
si je dois être mère
je le saurai par le vote par
l'expression du suffrage universel des
saint-andréens et saint-trond vrai mais
pas par le biais d'un passage de relais
internes qui malgré toujours pouvez vous
passer le relais à votre fils vous et
faire campagne pour lui vous êtes en
train de le faire là je vous explique
comment ça se passe aujourd'hui il a
démarré sa campagne le plus chez moi
j'ai pas me demander chaque empreinte
contre lui parce qu'il est intègre et il
a mis 13 ans pour apprendre le métier
un peu comme le métier de médecin
d'ailleurs qu'il est est ce que vous
comprends que ça puisse poser des
questions non pourquoi
soit aux rennais de dire que j'avais un
fils escrocs tard et incompétents et
vous le poussez et dans ce cas là je
comprends les interrogations mais là
aujourd'hui c'est sa campagne tout seul
je suis pas dans ces réunions et là des
gens se fait beaucoup plus vite que l'on
aurait pensé au point qu'on recherche un
adversaire actuellement il inquiet muet
il y en a qui y transitent
on aura l'occasion d'aider de faire les
deux en or lequel on parlait de sa
campagne visant qu'on a dans les moquées
les relations humaines sentimentale que
jean-marie entretient aujourd'hui avec
l'opinion publique saint-andréenne nous
laisse augurer d'un contrat de confiance
sans bavures entre lui et les intrants
vrai malgré tout est ce que vous
entendez on a entendu pendant le
mouvement des jeunes qu'il ya une façon
faire la politique à la réunion qui qui
qui ne va pas donc je ne veulent plus
cette façon peut-être aussi un peu de
passer ce relais dans la famille de
denain est ce que est ce que vous avez
entendu
est-ce que vous avez changé votre façon
ça la politique après ce mouvement
dijonnais ce que ça vous a parlé ce que
ça change et non parce que mon bureau il
est plus facile de rentrer dans mon
bureau comme h et de saint-andré moi je
compte y arriver la porte du secrétariat
du été collée à colle forte je voudrais
que les gens me disent on connaissait la
colle forte
on a vu des colis j'arrive à la mairie
passe passe de taille a dit le maire
d'aller là à midi à 1h13 n'est pas prêt
je les reçois dont il y ait une relation
constante on la population et nous
ériger des jeunes nous
reçu et je suis fier de dire si on a un
certain nombre aujourd'hui à qui on a
attribué des terres a duré et chant
train de monter des projets le dialogue
est constant gilet jaune le dialogue
constant avec la population sur le
terrain comprenez vous dites que je fais
campagne pour jean-marie microbienne r
j'ai fait lire à la réunion quand
victoria rentrée à mary sait ni quand
rami cars ou en trains mairie de
saint-louis et c'est extra la relève
j'ai fait lire tout ce que j'ai pu faire
et dire mais je n'ai aucune raison de ne
pas supporter quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui
rencontre large à des gens la population
et puis le résultat le contrat confiance
jean-marie ça serra dans le fauteuil de
maire de saint-andré s'il a
l'autorisation du peuple et du peuple
souverain
prémat est ce que le le clientélisme et
la façon de briller mairie est en train
de changer la réunion va changer où est
ce qu'on va continuer comme ces
dernières décennies et des emplois dire
va avoir le maire parce que c'est lui
qui peut c'est lui qui doit nous j'ai
envie de vous raconter une anecdote ce
vendredi dans mon bureau aujourd'hui le
clientélisme c'est quoi d'abord janvier
+1 tennis est ce qu un maire qui reçoit
comme j'ai commencé chez moi 300
personnes à semaine chez lui dans ma
permanence de la cour qui a qui on peut
téléphoner j'ai mon numéro de téléphone
tout le monde qu'on a bien des soucis
quand on obtient des voix en échange de
services dont pourra ça si vous trouvez
centre un saint-andréen qui vous dit que
je lui donnais un an propos voté pour
moi
vous menez a prouvé sa prof j'étais
battures 2008 je remue en 2014 nous
aurons n'est pas ce terrain là ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui les
la population saint-andré et je vous le
dis vous le verrez le résultat
à dr massivement à notre démarche
ces colosses magnifique projet si le
centre ville je vais être complètement
et qui recommence et rénover ses 32
écoles en bon état s'est dégradé qui
était en ruines il devait fermer du
temps d'eric fruteau qu'on a rénové
réouvert c'est qu'on a on a construit au
cours des cinq dernières années les deux
tiers des gares et de la réunion celle
usine de traitement d'eau potable qu'on
inaugure d'un mois avec l'aide de la
région didier robert
donc on est parent je ne donnerai une
époque où lyon brunet de l'immense joie
l'idrac rappelé le réunionnais atteint
aujourd'hui un degré d'information à
maturité politique
une indépendance de pensée qu on
l'achètera panier avec un bon d'ailleurs
les bonhommes et remy directement ccs
n'y avait qu'un emplois bidons qu'on
appelle les contrats aidés
le réunionnais a besoin que d'une
ambition et je veux avec jean-marie et
toute l'équipe municipale parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas tous seuls sont tous mes
conseillers 4e casier de faire campagne
10 restants d'ici jeudi si le d'ici le
mois de mars et lancé le conseil
municipal josette vk choisi deux de se
présenter elle est interviewée par nos
confrères du bien a dit que votre bio
est pas beau elle dit que vos colistiers
ont peur de parler que finalement vous
décider tout seul
est-ce que vous aussi vous avez une
personnalité un fonctionnement assez peu
de place à la discussion
ben c'est parce que je crois puisque ça
fait 50 ans qu'on voit ça fait une
personne qui pourra d'accord c'est son
drap se présenter et je lui ai dit
maintenant quand elle dit que on va lui
mener la vie dure c'est pas vrai elle se
présente a fait ça lisse yelp eux et les
520 trancheront tranquillement le débat
elle dit aussi que le saint-andré qu'a
connue
longtemps été agréable est sûr est que
ses poulains verse de la situation
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya un problème
aujourd'hui de sûreté de wilaya et abla
saint-andré parce que on l'entend quand
même beaucoup c'est vrai qu'on parle de
problèmes de sécurité
on parle de ces pseudo milices qui
s'installent pour faire la sécurité à la
sortie des établissements a disparu les
grands frères
ils ont disparu ils ont fait des
citrouilles 40 jose
c'est plus médiatique que réelle
aujourd'hui par l'un de ses surnoms
non puisque vous allez voir que la
délinquance à saint-andré il n'a pas pu
il n'ya pas réellement de délinquance et
par foyer des vols le vol s'est pas la
délinquance
du coup on va mettre une trentaine de
caméras je rends hommage travail de la
police d'état et la police municipale
bientôt nous serons nous au commissariat
ce qui compte dans cette affaire-là et
nous sommes à la pointe du progrès je
fais pas la pub pour la maison c'est
nous avons une grande politique de la
ville qui consiste non pas à mettre en
place à répression mais à mettre en
place la prévention et monsieur le
procureur la république monsieur eric
tuffery vient régulièrement malgré un
emploi du temps d'en faire il vient
régulièrement 6t à notre ciel spd et y
voit le travail de corps à corps que
nous faisons avec le spip pour les
jeunes qui sortent de prison
avec les jeunes qui veulent aller vers
la drogue avec les jeunes qui volent
c'est un travail de corps à corps le
résultat est faible c'est à dire qu'on
suivait vrais jeunes ou si vous avez
rattrapé 5 c'est bien mais nous on fait
l'effort de se rattraper 5
nous sommes chez des problèmes humains
avec manque de familles avec isolement
avec violence entre les parents tout ça
il faut reconstituer le cerveau du jeune
il faut lui redonner envie de se
mobiliser
c'est pas du bois c'est pas du béton ce
sont des êtres humains est en avance est
ce que la politique de logement on doit
évoluer à 100 dans l angoisse condé
on est tellement en avance que l'anru a
transformé avec mon avance sur quoi
servent saunière allez moi je vous
invite à venir faire un tour à la
cressonnière et vous verrez qu'on a
transformé ce quartier qui était cachée
far west est aujourd'hui la police
n'intervient presque plus à gasnier
nous avons six gymnases en tout dans la
ville et nous avons eu surtout
développer le sport pour faire entendre
un pôle artistique le plus de logements
sociaux moins de gens se souvenant quoi
ce que l'anru nous a dit la nasa n'a pas
rénovation urbaine qu'à signer l'anru 2
et ça me permet de vous dire que entre
le pont minots et le pont gustave a
transformé la ville que dans l'anru 2
l'an l'état ne veut plus qu'on
construise des logements centre-ville
passer un autre démon se serait ce qu'un
a trop on en construira un petit peu
quand même mais aujourd'hui ce qui
compte c est je remercie les bailleurs
sociaux à intéresser petits fans
demandent ils m'aident la tfnb sur dans
une caisse et avec ça je me comprennent
le logement c'est du béton mon rôle le
rôle de miss élues rôle de nos services
c'est la qualité de vie des êtres
humains qui habite dans ce béton et nous
nous faisons un effort considérable pour
qu'il y ait une politique humaniste 2
enfin la qualité de vie des gens qui
habitent d'un seul jean paul virapoullé
l'invité de lundi politique et 12h46
c'est l'heure des appels des auditeurs
s'il souhaite vous interroger et nous
avons virgile du port qui est en ligne
et bonjour j'ai votre question je me
suis dit il
je vous appelle c'est pour vous dire que
je suis je suis l'actualité la région et
si je me trompe sur ce que je vais vous
dire vous allez me remettre à ma place
non je vais crise et c'est pour vous
dire arrive en politique en 1970 par une
action cantonales 9 69 69 et ensuite
vous avez été élu maire je viens
d'entendre la queue
j'aurai une autre question un peu plus
importante à vous poser mais en
préambule je viens d'entendre que votre
fils jean marie virapoullé v est élu par
le peuple je pense que c'est une bonne
chose et c'est pas monsieur et d'élever
relative elle qui va qui est là où il
est dans sa tombe aujourd'hui qu'il va
nous dire le contraire
monsieur virapoullé cependant assez
élevés actuels l'ancien maire de
saint-andré c'est lui qui a démissionné
ce n'est pas moi qui les ai démissionné
oui non mais c'est à dire que l'on de
l'élection du maire on passe au dessus
je reviens je vote carrière politique de
bain 2020 s'avancer à 50 ans non cette
année ça fait cinquante ans que vous
êtes en politique c'est bien ça mais ces
questions je voulais vous
jean-pierre la situation la réunion la
réunion détient tous les records de
criminalité de la police
c'est sûrement du travail du chômage le
manque de logements déjà en perte de
repères est-ce que lorsque vous tombez
le soir vous avez vous avez l'esprit
tranquille ce que vous pouvez vous
regarder dans une glace répond
tranquillement
merci mais s'il agit pour ce qu'est ce
qui est très très clairs là le prisme la
loupe avec laquelle vous regardez la
réunion est complètement déformés y a
pas un pays écoutez moi ce que vous dire
y'a pas un pays dans la région qui peut
soigner vous soigne et me soigner
soigner les 800 réunionnais comme à la
réunion
allez faire un tour au chu de st pierre
de cette trempe de sani dans les
cliniques aussi un et vous verrez quelle
est la qualité des soins
quelle est la qualité la politique de
santé deuxièmement ya pas une région
autour de nous qui est une politique de
scolarisation comment la réunion il n'y
a pas une région autour de nous qu'un
niveau de vie égale à la réunion il n'ya
pas une pression autour de nous qui
logent les gens et qu'ils reçoivent une
allocation logement au cap et autour de
nous n'a pas ça quand je me regarde un
gage
j'ai dit j'ai bien fait de combattre
l'autonomie du parti communiste j'ai
bien fait de lutter aux côtés de michel
debré pour faire ce que nous avons fait
marrer
non et quand je me promène tout seul a
rugi je me suis jamais premier cas grave
d'uchronie zec et chauffeurs le problème
en voiture les gens quand ils me
rencontrent ils me disent toujours merci
de ce que vous avez fait pour la réunion
et voyez-vous votre jugement il est faux
reprenez vos livres d'histoire et révisé
je ne voulais plus malgré tout lorsque
gilles il dit par du chômage
il parle de perte de repères il ya aussi
une réalité à prendre quand on voit le
vote dernières élections européennes où
le rassemblement national arrive en tête
dans toutes les communes de la réunion
est ce que vous sentez pas qu'un
problème c'est aux inventé les problèmes
pour vous donner bonne conscience que ça
sera les médias où il ya gilles et vous
dire une chose je chômage d'ici endémie
que ça j'ai 32 ans d'ananas
ils seraient pas contraints d'arrêter ou
de ne pas faire suffisamment d'hectares
d'ananas à sa patte madame vous devez
vous dire que là les chiffres du chômage
ne sont pas le reflet la réalité u10
dont la réalité c'est du bidon tourna
libre au nom tout le monde s'installe
dans son confort de vie il ya ceux qui
vont pas le travail sortir et à ceux qui
l'ont soutenu
les crédits de la solidarité et c'est
pour ça que je félicite le conseil
départemental
cyrille melchior et jean marie
virapoullé ont tous obtenu ensemble le
transfert du rsa vers l'état mais ont
aussi obtenu que nous allons
expérimenter ce que j'appelais le rm
avant mais le cumul du travail et la
solidarité ou touche rsa ou va toucher
un complément de revenu il comprend pas
intéressant pour tout le monde les voit
frais travail
aujourd'hui il y a monsieur le dantec et
fosun est bien ça n'a peut-être faut
parler vrai pour aller loi et moi je
parle vrai pour aller dois je dis
qu'aujourd'hui la télescopage en
solidarité et travail il faut harmoniser
solidarité et travail et vous verrez le
chemin nous avons alix de saint pierre
qui est également une question pour vous
rejoindre x en écoute secondes
tout le monde chez virapoullé juste
interdit je suis propre parole du
collectif ville et citoyennes à 7,4 il
tombe bien que la ruche sujet du cumul
du rsa la recentralisation du récent que
le département a fait voter une motion e
la semaine d'avant dont l'avait fait la
demande à la région aussi les nanas une
motion qui a été voté n'était dans ce
sens là mais plus pour l'aide de la
proportion de 20 6 millions que les
tailles de bonnet tu mets donc le projet
que au le conseil général a fait voter
une motion nous au niveau du collectif
nous l'avait déjà fait élaborer un
projet dans ce sens
d'abord été déjà depuis la visite du
moose de l'autre nerfs au man band
elle était déjà dans ses mains est la
bienvenue aux dernières nouvelles que
nous la livre était déjà dans les droits
des ministères
il nous l'avait demandé à titre
expérimental parce que là trois régions
métropole fait déjà pendant l'évidence
les vendanges l'alsace la
charente-maritime et récemment la
dordonne la met à aurillac le dispositif
nous nous l'a demandé dans la motion
dans le projet que m acquitter
sperimentale à la réunion à 10 poissons
du chômage en métropole
pana et crient au scandale et nous a
pris 2,35 poisson ben nous reste là nous
reste immobile et nous nous ne disons
pas ne pas le prendre mais jamais une
passe et nous nous la proposer ça
d'ailleurs je dois avoir un rendez vous
sutout avec le président du département
subventions nous va présenter le projet
nous l'a déjà eu un premier contact nous
va accentuer ce contact
nous ne veux pas être comme x ali ciotti
je voudrais que les choses qui sont
accueillants sont arrivés en fin
d'émission
mais nouvelle partenaire et yoann c'est
une force de propositions pour l'avenir
nous les vrais le terrain revendicatif
mais nous la passer à autre chose
c'était un réveil des consciences
maintenant nous veut proposer et
proposer des projets réunionnais pour
que la réunion avance ils sont de
ceux-là et passe merci merci merci pour
votre participation est bonne
square vient d'exprimer et je félicite
et si les jeunes je les reçois
régulièrement ils sont plus du tout la
logique de la contestation sont bien
faits de viol et il n'était pas content
mais mène à idaho que ça nous fait durer
ils vont créer une
j'avais donné des termes vous avez prêté
l'état oui pour faire dépendre les dix
inhalé prendra pas fin pour faire des
vagues et bientôt ils vont avoir un
poids septembre et pour enseigner le
tourisme ce sont eux là où il y avait la
case du peuple maintenant ça devienne
cabane touristique et vont servir de
guide aux touristes rivaux la réunion
est une région où la population est
celle dédiée de creuser ce prix bien sûr
premier violent alcoolique tous habillés
en a partout mais ici on a et je salue
d'ailleurs à mémoire de boris gamaleya
et ça avait c'est un homme de culture
c'est un homme qui a influencé la
culture réunionnaise et je voudrais lui
rendre hommage en citant une de ces
belles pensées y lisait là où se
rencontrent les races mais la culture
nous sommes un peuple cultivé et jeudi à
ce monsieur
voyez belle quand vous voyez jean marie
virapoullé sans train d'écrire avec vous
le cumul de la solidarité et du travail
remplissent développer la réunion
c'était le air et mac j'avais prévu à
l'époque on l'appelle comme on veut
on le fait à titre expérimental comme
les autres départements dans le
département de l'ain également métropole
bon les gars qui vient il était pas
vraiment l'ami de votre ami devrait non
mais vous savez la qualité des hommes ne
se fait pas par classification
idéologique il avait ses défauts il
avait ses qualités
moi j'étais plus proche de debray que
lui bien sûr mais n'empêche que monsieur
verbal est un homme de qualité
on rêve en toute fin d'émission juste un
mot
on a politique politicienne mais
globalement un mot sur la situation de
la droite réunionnaise qui on va dire
désunis elle a gagné les dernières des
dernières élections locales grâce à une
plate forme d'union sur la
départementale et régionale
là là on ajoute la guerre entre michel
fontaine et et didier robert empêche
cette union et que est-ce que ça va
poser comment ce que vous voyez tout ça
en moi je le dis il faut pas jouer
enfant gâté le camp qui est divisé et le
cran qui perd la droite a toujours gagné
avec la relève rappelez-vous coupe à
londres a avancé de 19 et riesch 24
toutes les communautés de communes aux
régionales cantonales et municipales de
2014 nous avons gagné aux municipales
c'était pas trop l'union berlin gagner
quand même et puis on a construit
l'union pour les cantonales et
régionales
je leur dis faites taire vos querelles
de personnes au profit de l'intéressé
s'est entendu pour l'instant moyennement
mais déçu persévérant je suis sûr que
quand je regarde au fond de leurs yeux
je sens qu'il y a un peu d'amertume mais
qui a aussi une envie de dire gg en
train de faire ce qui est pas bon pour
la réunion il faudra tota on revienne
là-dessus et moi j'appelle toutes les
forces à se réunir parce qu'ils manquent
pas d'idées il ment pas de crédit il
ment pas d'orientation futur ils n'ont
pas de potentiel terre stable garanties
sécuritaires sur la route des bateaux
autres en chef je vous ai pas cité mais
mon vrai vitréens où il fallait pour
vous parler des nodules polymétalliques
que l'on procède à notre océan
l'occasion de reprendre sa juste un
dernier mot vous serez donc pas candidat
à la mairie de saint-andré vous c'est
sur la lys vous ça sur la liste sans
opposition jean-marie mois d'amaryllis
château et moi donc on vous entendra
bien sûr
et est-ce qu'on vous on verra ensuite
pour les régionales pour le départ sans
cesse que à mental c'est plus possible
du mondial mais les régionales je pense
que j'ai encore des choses à dire pour
l'avenir la réunion et j'irai jusqu'au
bout de mes forces et j'ai donc jusqu'au
bout de l'aboutissement du projet d'éco
technopole on vous sait grand père mon
grand père toujours en politique jean
politique mais le week-end c'est pour un
petit enfant devront témoigner
merci beaucoup je peux bien plus d'avoir
été notre invité pour ce dernier numéro
de la saison de lundi politique qu'on
retrouve bien sûr à la rentrée dès la
fin du mois d'août demain à cette heure
là ce sera le dernier club de la presse
de la saison également avec nous un
instant bien sûr c'est la musique avec
sonia vous passionner ses journées à
l'ecoute de la première
le